ça parle de vous de vos douze ans par
exemple ou découvrez votre corps et le
miroir qui va avec et le miroir c'est
aussi le regard des autres c'est
complètement le regard des autres c'est
complètement le le
problème de enfin le problème le fait
que ce soit un problème ce rapport au
corps ce rapport à soi-même c'est c'est
clairement une chanson où je dis que
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais que je
me suis sentie comme une merde et que
j'espère j'espère vraiment que que le
monde va évoluer dans dans un autre sens
en fait ces années là elles sont une
instigmate encore très profond bien sûr
elles sont en stigmates encore très
profond c'est dingue parce que très
récemment dans un entretien avec un
média je discutais et je revenais à ok à
quel moment exactement j'ai commencé à
me sentir moins bien dans mon corps et
je me rappelle exactement de cet instant
là et je me dis en fait c'est à cause de
trois personnes quoi c'est à cause de
trois personnes quand j'avais 12 ans qui
avaient eux-mêmes 12-13 ans et on se
rend pas compte à quel point en fait
c'est c'est un événement marquant et je
me suis rendu compte à ce moment-là que
souvent les adultes se disent et disent
aux enfants mais c'est pas grave les
enfants ils sont méchants entre eux mais
c'est pas grave et ben en fait si c'est
grave c'est hyper grave c'est hyper
violent et parfois on se retrouve des
années et des années après en souffrir
encore alors que c'est une petite phrase
qui a l'air complètement
inoffensif mais qui est balancé au
mauvais moment et un instant qui est
compliqué qui reste qui reste
douloureuse jusqu'à ce que j'ai 26 ans
elle l'est encore quoi mais est-ce que
quand même